less than three weeks away from the
start of hybrid learning for some
students within the clark county school
district
on march 1st they'll begin attending
school in person two days
and online the other three ccsd has
finally released the results from a
recent survey
regarding that return kristen drummond
joins us live in the newsroom with those
kristin
well christian the survey revealing more
than 50 percent of lower elementary
school families and staff
plan to come back in buildings but
responses were only submitted by
75 percent of the 85 000
pre-kindergarten to
third grade students the data shows here
on your screen about 56 percent of
students
plan to come back while the other 44.44
will continue full-time distance
education meanwhile a separate employee
survey shows nearly
60 percent of staff want to work on
campus while roughly 40 percent prefer
still working remotely
a breakdown of each school was not
available today but i did request it
now one thing to take note of is the
numbers may not indicate the reality of
each campus
one parent tells me the harmon
elementary school administration tells
her
hardly any students plan to return
there's only a small handful of
kids that are doing the hybrid at our
school
i mean like under 15. i reached out to
harman elementary school but was told to
contact the district
ccsd says elementary schools will share
plans for transitioning to hybrid
learning
as well as continuing full-time distance
education
now the district wants to transition
more grade levels to hybrid learning
this semester
but there's still no timeline for when
that may happen
reporting live in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now